okay you've graduated all right what's
next so now we're going to do the real
thing and do a fake movie we're doing
the real thing that was now you're gonna
do it against other people and we'll
incorporate this into a movie fight
what movie is this we'll figure it out
let's get the guys out this is biodome
4. all right you can set the scenario we
have
we have three thugs two baseball bats a
crowbar and an Asian baby that's what we
have
so you guys are a baby you set the
scenario and I'll set the uh the action
if you'd like uh let's see this is uh a
gay couple that's adopted a child
foreign
Andy help me out what's the scenario
here now these three thugs stole a baby
right right and they're named small
medium and large
and I gotta stop them and they see me
coming and I'm gonna try and save that
baby see right right you got to save the
baby all right whatever what are you
doing that's my foot what are you doing
making sure they're rubber man will you
ask me first next time
so real quick you're gonna have to pay
attention very quickly we're gonna I'm
gonna walk through this one time okay
you're gonna pick it up on the Fly Then
You're Gonna Do It full speed gotcha
okay so Don's gonna come with the
Crowbar you're gonna weave under
breakfast right okay we've under back
fist we've under back fish Adam's gonna
come let's look to the right cross there
okay left then right got it okay Kevin's
gonna come big clothesline wow okay and
drop them all right let's do it pick up
his basement pick up his baseball bat oh
there's just keep the scene yeah why
does Adam comes he's gonna take a
leaping dive get out of the way hit him
in the ass
come back here
Smackdown in the legs why is he charging
me with a baby
the baby he dropped the Crowbar to
charge me with a baby
strong head strong hands
Terrible Bad Guys
and a four-month-old
see you later crowbar
okay here we go
first one you want to just do it walk
through it come on okay I fight this
every day in my mind so make sure you
duck make sure you duck under okay I
think I got it hold on yeah and action
[Applause]
this guy comes at me
[Music]
oh
my God
[Applause]
baby's fine all right
where'd they go oh
congratulations thank you so much thanks
for being here Stephen ho everybody
we'll be right back